so what's the long-term plan for you
like is this going to be a lifelong
career or is you ride it until the
wheels fall off no I honestly I'm really
into like the music festival world and
like I really have been passionate about
like Event Photography and stuff um like
film photography particularly so that's
like where my passion is and honestly
I've been getting a lot of bookings
lately so I think I will be able to kind
of like use only fans as like a crutch
but like do what I'm actually more
passionate about now I used to be really
passionate about only fans so Jasmine do
you have a like is there an exit
strategy or is it just you know R into
the wheels fall off sort of thing for
you right into so the wheels fall off
and then probably get into a little bit
more of social commentary those kinds of
things because there seems to be an
interest for people to for people um for
me to make that kind of content so you
have a YouTube channel
right pretty I had it for a while but I
just started pushing out the content huh
do people follow follow you for the
social commentary yeah I actually and I
get a ton of subscribers for it you
would have you have no idea how many
people because I have a pretty big
Reddit profile that's where I get most
of my I have like millions of followers
on Reddit and there's a lot of people
who are like oh my God I saw you on
Reddit and then I went to your YouTube
and I loved what you were saying or I
love how you speak or I love like it's
it is a big turn on to a lot of people
and then and then that draws them into
the subscriber to yeah sometimes and
some people are just like hey start a
podcast I'm really interested in this
you know
whatever interesting yeah that's way
more lucrative than law short hours too
for
sure would you if you had daughters
would you encourage them to do what
you're doing right now if I had
daughters the only thing I'd want for
them is for them to be nice people and
for them to be happy and healthy so if
it was like a situation like me yeah if
it was if if if only fans did for them
what it's done for my life and they had
the head on the shoulder the head on the
shoulders like I feel like I do then
yeah go for it the um interview you did
on the the soft white soft white
underbelly that I listened to you
mentioned something about your dad um
sort of having a sit down talk with you
um rather than the others in your family
he basically said look you know you need
to go back to school donate all the
money to CH charity stop this but you
didn't really follow up after that I was
curious you know what were the
conversations after that there was going
drawn by I was already I had already
taken the bar so I was done with all
that I sorry going back to work or
something um
and yeah I said no and we didn't talk
for a few months but then eventually
they call me and they're like both my
Mom and Dad we love you anyway um we
don't agree with what you're doing but
you're still our daughter and actually
my Dad's here making me dinner right now
nice yeah it sounded like you had a good
relationship with him so the whole
You've Got daddy issues is completely
out the window right yeah I'm very close
to my dad in fact the only kind of daddy
issue I have is that I was extremely
like favored and spoiled by my dad so
like he almost like some people are like
he's made you a narcissist which I don't
I not saying that that's true but yeah
he just from when I was a kid first of
all super involved um we talk for hours
a day still like I'm such a daddy's girl
always have been I have do you guys both
want to have a family and
children I have a question for Jasmine
really quick yeah go for it um do you
think that like you having a better
relationship with your dad like upped
your standards for your relationships
with like men
absolutely absolutely I do believe that
100% because one thing about me is I've
never dated an [__] I've never dated
a guy that was rude disrespectful to me
or anyone that didn't treat me very well
and I do attribute some of that to the
fact that that's how my dad always
treated me so I think there is some good
there's a good basis in believing that
your relationships with your parents
especially early childhood does
determine sometimes how you act now it
doesn't mean you can't break out of
those patterns but I do think in my case
like I always had high self-esteem um
partially because my dad always told me
I was a [__]
so um back question those relationship
worked out H goad I curious up to this
point if there hasn't been any toxicity
or this and that like why why Haven
those relationships I've only had two
relationships the first one we were
together for four years he went to
medical school I went to law school so
we just moved apart and then the second
one was a guy I was dating in law school
and yeah we just started bickering and
stuff um once Co hit because we were
together 247 we're still friends but I
we're just not together anymore I mean
most relationships end that's that's
also statistically accurate so most
relationships endare yeah I'm aware I
think a lot of times though what we hear
is that it's a very common occurrence
where we hear women say oh he was toxic
like the new one that we're hearing a
lot of is like oh I was in a an abusive
relationship and he was emotionally
abusive and so um you know but I know
you've said that you would wouldn't get
married I've heard you say stuff like
that so um so that's fine that makes
sense so okay so that kind of leads on
my next question because I was asking
you know did you have plans to get
married have a a family you know
children uh I I was going to let Liz
answer because I feel like I don't want
to I always get accused of hijacking the
show so I don't want to hijack the show
goez um I want to one day but I'm 23 so
I'm kind of just I'm not really looking
they say good things find you when
you're not looking so I'm like
I'm not young I'm just you're still
extremely young so you're not in any
Rush um for me if I did have I I don't
want to get married as I might get
married legally just for the incentives
like legal incentives um but I when it
comes to Children I'd want them in my
mid-30s if that in your mid-30s isn't
that a bit late though um well one uh I
don't really care if they're biological
I wouldn't mind adopting I'm pretty rich
I can afford IVF if I need to but I
would rather wait until I'm retired um
and I'm ready for
kids okay yeah I mean if you have the
means I guess you could even buy a
surrogate to to do all the work for you
and everything right if I need to yeah
um have either of you given any thought
to what your current career might do to
affect that in the future do you think
it will
or uh do you want to go first or I I
don't think it will because I just like
I it does I just won't be with that
person and that's my simple answer yeah
yeah what about you Jasmine and then for
me I've never liked guys that had an
issue with only fans so even like two
years ago I didn't have any social media
at all and I was never attract like if
even at that time if a guy was like I
would never date someone on only fansy
when I I would never talk to him I'm
just not into that guy so for me my
dating prospects have remained pretty
much exactly the same America you're
right sorry I think in North America
you're right there's there's going to be
an there's going to be way more guys
that'll just look past it then we'll
have an issue with it I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out